[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
premier numéro du 7 8 sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour débattre
discuter et réfléchir sur les grands
enjeux qui touchent nos vies et qui font
l'actualité
et pour ce premier numéro nous allons
parler de vivre ensemble et du regard
envers les autres autour du handicap en
france près de 12 millions de personnes
sont reconnus en situation de handicap
c'est un français sur cinq handicap
moteur handicap mental handicap lourd ou
encore handicap léger
si l'on parle souvent d'inclure ces
français aujourd'hui nous avons choisi
de changer de regard et de voir comment
les valides peuvent aussi être inclus
dans ce questionnement et trois invités
sont avec nous ce soir pour échanger sur
ce sujet en plateau morgane le grand
bonjour nous vous êtes vous même en
situation de handicap puisque vous êtes
mal voyantes et à partir du mois
d'octobre
nos téléspectateurs pourront vous
retrouvez sur notre antenne puisque vous
animerez votre propre émission avec les
yeux de morgan dans laquelle vous allez
débattre échanger sur de nombreuses
thématiques autour du handicap
oriane nino bonjour vous êtes la
directrice de théâtre
eurydice c'est un visa d'un
établissement et service d'aidé par le
travail il est situé à plaisir et parce
que les conditions sanitaires actuelles
ne nous permettent pas de recevoir tout
le monde de manière physique
nous avons en visio annick bouquay
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la présidente
de l'association nouvelle du vivre
ensemble une association installée à
versailles alors pour changer le regard
il faut parler du handicap avec tous
morgan legrand j'aimerais commencer en
vous posant une question dans quelques
jours à les enregistrer le premier
numéro de votre émission une émission
consacrée à l'inclusion du monde valide
dans le monde du handicap mais déjà
comment est née cette émission cette
émission elle a vu le jour suite alors à
l'engagement fort des acteurs autour de
ce projet et aussi pour recentrer le
débat sur des sujets d'actualité et de
la vie quotidienne donc
en ayant toujours en fil conducteur
l'inclusion et en ayant vraiment la
volonté de bien faire pour faire
entendre la voix de celles et ceux qui
sont concernés par le handicap de près
ou de loin et faire entendre cette voix
que parfois on entend et bien
malheureusement qu en fond sonore est
justement pourquoi cet angle d'inclure
les valides souvent on parle de de la
notion dans l'autre sens c'est afin
d'inverser la tendance voilà on prend
les choses à revers ici et surtout
inclure les valide parce que les valides
ont peut-être envie de mieux comprendre
de s'intéresser de s'impliquer mais
encore faut-il voilà quelque part leur
en donner la possibilité est là où
quelqu'un en situation de handicap
arrive à se projeter dans la vie de
quelqu'un de valide a imaginé cette vie
et 20 al'inverse quelqu'un de valide qui
n'a pas voilà de problèmes de santé va
avoir du mal à imaginer un petit peu
tous les aspects de la vie avec un
handicap
une émission que l'on pourra retrouver
sur internet et on peut être casté
j'imagine c'est pour toucher un plus
grand public complètement in était
important d'utiliser différents supports
effectivement pour que ce soit adaptée
et adaptable du coup pour correspondre à
tout le monde qu'on puisse regarder et
écouter
alors avant d'échanger plus longuement
avec nos invités je vous propose qu'on
regarde un reportage nous sommes partis
à la rencontre de guillaume le bio c'est
un jeune yvelinois il est aujourd'hui
handicapé à la suite d'un accident
regarder il y a un an un accident prévu
guillaume le bilan de sa jambe droite
âgé aujourd'hui de 22 ans il redécouvre
la vie autonome dans son appartement
rambolitains qu'il occupe depuis juillet
ou pas l'impression d'être quelqu'un de
si handicap ex entre guillemets nous
sort comme tout le monde je fais mes
courses comme tout le monde je vais
aller voir mes amis comme tout le monde
mise à part la prothèse là qu'on voit là
pas de pas de problème le premier jour à
la fac avant avant que je dise que
j'avais une prothèse
au début il pensait que j'avais une
entorse ou quelque chose comme ça
sinon ça me ça me pose pas de problème
juste les enfants des phoques et morgane
rien il a une jambe robot à quel gamin
c'est un pirate depuis le mois de
septembre il a pris le chemin de
l'université équipé d'une prothèse
ancien serveur dans la restauration
guillaume a choisi de reprendre ses
études ou avec le fait de rester assis
derrière une chaise à écouter un prof
pendant plus de deux heures un peu
difficile je suis quelqu'un qui aime
bien bouger on ne peut pas rester assis
à rien faire pour ça que la restauration
ça me plaisait je bouge je suis toujours
en activité et je prends à 6 rien faire
ou pire des cas je suis debout a essuyé
des verts une installation solitaire
facilité par son quotidien avant
l'accident et une reprise d'autonomie
très attendu même si son appartement est
tout proche du logement de sa mère qu'il
est pour ses déplacements
le soulagement rigole c'est la vérité
oui comme un soulagement
le fait qu'ils reprennent une vie
autonome
indépendante et donc c'était c'était
agréable pour tout le monde on peut
commencer la valeur et je te dépose à la
fac et appâts jeune âge arena
cool je le fait qu'il soit pas loin je
me ça me rassure pas que j'étais
inquiète mais au moins je me dis s'il ya
besoin parce que dans un premier temps
pour aller faire les courses lorsque ça
c'est quand même plus facile quand ma
main et point qu'en étudiant à lui vécu
depuis la rentrée guillaume début d'une
licence d'histoire il rêve d'être un
jour consultant historique pour le
cinéma et le monde du jeu vidéo
de retour ce soir et cette suite société
et que nos invités
j'aimerais rebondir sur l'une des
phrases de guillon que l'on entend dans
le reportage n'a pas l'impression d'être
quelqu'un de six handicapés que ça il
répète comme tout le monde
comme tout le monde ils france pas
anodine morgan le gros tout à fait c'est
intéressant de l'entendre dire ça mais
justement on voit bien que peut-être on
se on se représente beaucoup de choses
on se fait tout hamon est en fait en
l'écoutant je nomme bas alors on se rend
compte que il est capable de tout et
qu'il a envie de tout
quelque part ça donne un bel exemple de
dynamisme derrière mais c'était très
intéressant et notamment quand il parle
aussi du regard des enfants très
intéressant est vraiment à l'e-book et
ce comme tout le monde ils poussent
notamment votre association a organisé
chaque année des olympiades
on développe le vivre ensemble on est
tous pareils alors d'abord je dirais que
cette différence la différence quelle
qu'elle soit ne devrait jamais une vigne
à la différence déjà première chose et
les olympiades en fait les idées quoi
les ai appelés vivre ensemble parce que
je suis convaincu que grâce au handicap
on va réapprendre les bases vivre
ensemble très souvent quand on est face
à une personne en difficulté on va dire
tiens je ferme à bhv la compagnie je
vais l'aider
donc on va aller vers la personne après
on va essayer de comprendre de quel est
son handicap parce que s'ils en fauteuil
s'il est mal voyance mais sourd et muet
donc on va peut s'oublier pour vraiment
se mettre dans la personne pour
l'accompagner au mieux
et puis quand on va à la compagne emma
des gens va toucher et puis on va te
rends compte que c'est une personne
comme une autre et puis je sais pas très
souvent on va mettre sont pas dans son
cas on va aller à son but est très
souvent à se rencontrer une personne
marc justement que c'est comme une autre
et même parfois qu'elle vous apporte
beaucoup et et quand on a fait ce genre
entre guillemets on pense une bm pense
qu'on
on a beaucoup plus reçu qu'on a de neige
est en fait ces olympiades
au départ c'était d'abord et que pour ça
c'est que c'était en fait pour les
valides qui en est en contact avec les
personnes handicapées est bon plus
recevoir est bon plus apprendre qu autre
chose surtout que les personnes
handicapées comme un abus dans
témoignage du jeune homme eh ben ils ont
une force de vie extraordinaire et c'est
une épée une belle leçon de vie donc en
fait on l'a souvent reçoit donc mille
personnes handicapées autant de
personnes valides c'est tout type de
handicap et le but c'est pareil c'est de
faire ensemble pour apprendre à mieux se
comprendre
c'est vraiment très très important vous
savez je viens de te passer par le sport
alors oui parce que ben on n'a pas
besoin de parler et puis souvent ont
fait ensemble on se touche ensemble on
mouille le maillot ensemble et il ya une
partie de jeu qui fait qu'on oublie ou
beaucoup de choses et c'est vraiment je
peux le dire une journée de vrais de
réelle bonne humeur donc si on comprend
bien pour inclure les valides il faut
informer voir éduquer oriane minot c'est
une notion qu'on trouve au théâtre
eurydice ce que les personnes en
situation de handicap sont partie
prenante de toutes les strates dans les
coulisses des techniciens des artisans
mais ils sont aussi sur scène et
certains fonds détournés tout à fait
c'est sam en est convaincu donc nous
sommes les acteurs et 10 on n'a plus
perdu avant du handicap psychique
donc c'est vrai qu'en plus cela c'est un
handicap qui ne se voit pas donc est
plus difficile à appréhender pour les
valides
voilà c'est vraiment quelque chose mais
on est convaincu que tout un chacun a
des compétences et c'est là dessus qu'on
insisté sur lequel on travaille tous les
jours avec des gens très compétents
je me suis pas régisseuse je ne sais pas
fabriquer un décor je ne sais pas coudre
un costume mais eux ils le savent
voilà ils ont des compétences là dedans
donc c'est vrai que il y a des mots sont
tous des professionnels qui sont formés
et accompagnés tous ses métiers
voilà comme vous le disiez très bien le
théâtre raidissent fonctionne grâce à
des personnes en situation de handicap
voilà il son régisseur ils sont là ils
travaillent à la billetterie à la
communication ils sont comédiens voilà
tout à fait et vous accompagnez 64
personnes reconnues travailleurs
handicapés c'est un nom conséquence
finalement j'avais quand même dur début
12 millions oui c'est le conséquent
après on voit qu on a beaucoup de
demandes
donc je pense que c'est conséquent mais
sûrement pas assez en plus comme c'est
des métiers assez comme vous l'avait dit
en début d'émission qui sont pas très
représentés dans les esat va tous les
comme sa fonction artistiques culturels
elle n'a pas beaucoup donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein de gens qui viennent un
peu de la france entière
donc on est quelques-uns en france à
avoir des troupes de comédiens en
situation de handicap mais par contre
d'avoir des créations décors costumes
tout ça voilà ça on est assez unique
dont serait qu'on a beaucoup de demandes
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
compétents dont même s'ils sont ils ont
un handicap physique qui leur empêche à
des moments de pouvoir travailler dans
le milieu qu'on appelle ordinaire voilà
ça n'empêche pas qu'ils sont vraiment
des compétences et c'est là dessus qu'on
les accompagne et on essaye de leur
montrer qu'ils ont une vraie utilité
sociale et qui peuvent après bien sûr
retravailler dans le milieu ordinaire
six ans non l'envi parce que ce que pas
forcément le cas
en tout cas on est aussi là pour les
insérer leurs oeufs enfin prendre
conscience vraiment de leurs compétences
pour certains qui manquerait un peu pour
certains destine de soi ou de
revalorisation de soi parce que souvent
ils ont eu un parcours un peu difficile
voilà tout type de handicap fait que des
fois le parcours est pas évident mais
aujourd'hui en tout cas ceux qui
viennent les aides je pense que voilà
ils sont contents et non les content
aussi de les accompagner au quotidien
sur leur parcours qu'ils ont choisi un
ebook est justement par le sport ce que
là le théâtre c'est pour tout le monde
on va voir une pièce qu'on ne s'attende
pas nécessairement que le comédien soit
schizophrène ou tout autre tout autre
handicap mental
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas faire des
compétitions sportives ou bien sans
maître validé pizzeria et un 100 mètres
d'une perte de personnes en situation
d'handicap mais dans une même
compétition
alors ça se fait ou alors ça se fait on
a déjà fait au niveau la natation que
oulaye
les tribunes sont remplis toujours pour
les valides et candiac
quand s'est séparé qu'elle est
compétition non valide a plus personne
eh ben on a fait des compétitions avec
une partie va vider une partie non
valides m'avait tout le public présent
et je peux vous dire que
quand les non valides participent à ce
moment là sa crête des émotions
extrêmement fort le public est
extraordinaire et rien et personne est
indifférent et je voulais dire que la
partie la deuxième objectif de mon
association
suite aux olympiades justement d'inclure
le les personnes handicapées tout type
de handicap
autant mentales que physiques
sensorielles au sein des associations
sportives dire que très souvent pour
faire du sport et ben il y en a très peu
qui sont accessibles et qui sont
adaptées aux personnes essaient de
montrer cotation sportives qu'elles
peuvent intégrer du handicap que c'est
possible
il ya juste une volonté après il ya
peut-être des moyens pour adapter mais
voilà on peut le faire et c'est quelque
chose qu'on développe de plus en plus
dans ce main versailles mais aussi dans
les yvelines moyen de mignoni nos pardon
vous disais qu'il ya souvent un manque
de confiance dans le travail c'est
compliqué on sait que le taux de chômage
des personnes en situation de handicap
en 2019 ses 16%
c'est deux fois plus élevé que celui de
la population active est ce que au
siècle quotas qui met en place par
l'état on ne s'attache pas qu un
handicap plutôt qu'aux capacités du
salarié je sais pas je vois bien que
l'anneau on est quand même en contact
avec beaucoup d'entreprises
aujourd'hui je pense vraiment les
entreprises enfin en tout cas pour ceux
qu'on a eu en contact ils ont vraiment
une vraie volonté et ils sont plutôt
consciente des compétences des personnes
après dans le cas du handicap psychique
quand quelqu'un va être en fauteuil
l'adaptation du poste de travail peut
être entre guillemets plus simple en
tout cas c'est il ya des choses
concrètes peuvent être faites
le handicap psychique là les entreprises
elles ont besoin si être un peu
accompagner parce que travailler avec
une personne schizophrène qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
et même nous on peut pas dire
schizophrène césaire faudra travailler
comme c'est annoncé une personne unique
donc forcément adaptée à chaque fois
qu'il faut s'adapter à chaque personne
est aujourd'hui ce qui est très
intéressant nous aussi dans notre
travail c'est d'amener les personnes qui
ont un handicap à réussir à dire où sont
leurs difficultés et elles se
connaissent très bien donc on a des gens
chez nous qui qui vont aller voir leur
employeur qui vont lire bon si jamais tu
commence à voir que je commence à
m'habiller comme ça où je commence à me
coiffer c'est que là je suis en train de
partir sur une mauvaise base est dû
cd des petites choses qui est utile pour
valides ou pour voilà le l'employeur
pour dire ok l'info lors que je l'aide
parce que là elle m'a donné un
indicateur et ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui
dans le secteur médical ça se passe on
se connaît très bien et bien dans le
secteur aussi du handicap en tout cas la
psy chic les personnes commencent à se
connaître elles savent quand elles sont
en train de voilà un peu en train de
glisser morgan dont je vous ai vu
acquiescé c'est ça en fait se présenter
en entretien de bouche c'est pareil pour
tous oui oui oui
résolument sais c'est pareil pour tout
le monde les qualités et les motivations
conte et handicap ou pas on les a mais
pour rebondir sur l'inclusion dans le
monde de l'emploi
il ya des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens et il compris les quotas alors oui
oui c'est vrai que ça peut être perçu
comme une barrière après ça peut aussi
être un levier et heureusement il ya de
belles initiatives autour par exemple je
pense à l'officialisation du statut de
référents handicap au sein des
entreprises notamment des grosses
entreprises qui est fait pour voir pour
aller de l'avant et c'est donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne chose
et derrière au delà du côté officiel du
référent eh bien il ya des entreprises
qui qu'elle ait un référent ou non elles
ont la volonté de bien faire et donc ça
bouge ça bouge quand même je voulais
repartir sur le monde de la culture
parce que c'est la particularité de
votre esat
c'est aussi une manière de prouver que
la culture c'est pour tout le monde ou
peut être une personne en situation de
handicap aller dans la salle
tout ça n'est pas tout ça c'est vrai que
c'est une relation notre côté militant
aussi c'est ça je pense que
l'accessibilité ça va aussi ça c'est
l'accessibilité de la salle
là en ce moment partir du 19 septembre
jusqu'à jusqu'à 1000 et son il ya le
festival magot voilà qui est une des
représentations voilà de montrer que
vraiment le talent des artistes en
situation de handicap et là ils sont sur
scène et on voit je pense que voilà si
on a envie de rire on rit parce que
c'est un bon comédien ce parce que voilà
il y en a pas un qui faisait voir mais
j'ai l'impression de me moquer mais non
rist a envie de rire tu pleures tu as
envie de pleurer
voilà c'est parce que c'est un bon
comédien aussi et c'est ça qui est
agréable je pense qu'il faut que chacun
des grands exemples guillaume bats qui
fait se marrer des foules je pensais
aussi à le comédien peter dinklage game
of thrones qui est un qui fait révélée
dans la série red charme
il ya en nous des exemples on peut
montrer les valides regardez ils sont là
mais justement quand on va à la
rencontre un public dit valide chaque
année il ya des nombreuses communes qui
font des semaine du handicap c'est des
moments des changes pour faire
comprendre mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant salah celle qui veut répondre
d semaine du handicap finalement ce que
ça devrait pas être tous les jours
alors je vais je suis totalement
d'accord après c'est ce qu'on essaye de
voir ce que les entreprises
en même temps ça nous permet de démarrer
des choses je pense que c'est bien parce
que ça permet d'avoir un pied de
démarrer des choses après bien sûr il
faut l'aider mais il faut le continuer
et après il ya quand même là pendant
dans le cadre de la commune de plaisir
auquel on participe pour la semaine du
handicap il ya l'unafam que
l'association justement pour aider les
familles avec qui sont qui qui sont
touchés par le handicap psychique
justement ils ont mis en place une
énorme bulle
donc c'était dans la galerie d'auchan où
il y avait une énorme bulle et du coup
quelqu'un doit se mettre dans cette
bulle et se rendre compte que c'est
difficile de rentrer un contact
interagir comme ça avec l'autre avec
cette double donc en même temps ça
permet d'avoir quand même des focus
après bien sûr je pense qu'on est tous
là aujourd'hui c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
est là pour faire
des piqûres de rappel en tout cas que ça
devienne dans le quotidien de tout un
chacun mais je pense qu'on a encore
besoin d'avoir des semaines phare pour
que pour avoir un peu de faire beaucoup
de communication publicis pour ces deux
choses m'ont rien de vaut à vue
complètement complètement on va se
rejoindre là dessus c'est déjà bien
effectivement certaines actions mais il
ya toujours besoin mais après oui ce
type d'action allait permettre de faire
un pont avec certains milieux avec les
communes avec les entreprises on sait
déjà super mais il ya des sujets qui
méritent d'être portées et au quotidien
etc c'est pas avant nous mais en même
temps porter des valeurs de solidarité
et d'éthique de morale bien sûr que non
ces paravents et donc porter cette cause
du handicap
ça n'est jamais un vain mot mais
heureusement il ya beaucoup d'action
autour de ça et notamment de la
sensibilisation où je pense aux tournées
d'été qui ont été organisées par une
association en occurrence s'appelle
france handicap et qui permettait
d'aller à la rencontre du grand public
qui pouvait venir rire échanges et poser
des questions par exemple un netbook et
lorsque nous avons échangé en préparant
cette émission aviez dit en plus qu'un
accident de vie ça peut arriver du jour
au lendemain on vieillit on peut devenir
handicapé avec la vieillesse
j'imagine que ce genre de journée ça
fait aussi réagir c'est pas parce que un
matin on se réveille valide que le
lendemain on sera toujours valide il
faut que tout le monde comprenne qu'on
est tous un moment donné vulnérables
qu'on est tous fragiles qu'on l'ait
quand on est enfant on l'est parfois
aussi quand on est femme par rapport à
des rapports de force
et puis qu'on l'ait quand on a un
accident de la vie comme le jeune homme
ce qui lui est arrivé ou par exemple on
sait qu'on va lire c'est une chance de
vieillir et qu'on deviendra vulnérables
et je trouve que fo personne ne l'oublié
que dans ces moments là on est bien
content on ne peut on est des regards
bienveillants qu'on ait une matante uc
on a tous besoin de sa portée les uns
les autres de s'épauler de céder et
c'est vrai que quand je confirme que
conduit les deux autres invités on a
besoin de ces journées c'est semaine de
sensibilisation de d'en parler de
l'évoquer et moi je rajouterais on a
besoin des quotas comme on a besoin par
exemple en politique la parité pour la
voilà une fois il faut passer par là
pour se rendre compte que oui chacun
bien sa place mais je dirais aussi qu'il
faut éduquer et de pieds au des plus
jeune âge et pour ça faut l'inclusion
dans les écoles dans les crèches pour se
rendre que weeds et l'autre est
peut-être différent mais que cette
différence est une richesse pour tout le
monde
alors qu'est-ce qui est aujourd'hui en
2020 qu'est ce qui manquerait qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait mettre en place pour
aller encore plus loin que ce qui est
déjà prévu une question mais dans la
continuité de ce qui s'est déjà quelque
part il ya déjà encore une fois beaucoup
de belles actions mais c'est aussi au
pouvoir décisionnel après de porter ce
genre de chose chacun ce qu'on fait ça
ça a du poids ça a de l'importance il ya
pas de plus de petits gestes mais après
faut être exemplaire et les pouvoirs
décisionnels et politiques se doivent de
s'emparer de ce genre de sujet avec vous
qu'êtes vous vouliez réagir bah je suis
tout à fait d'accord et bijoux et dire
que on a quand même un titre associatif
extraordinaire je connais bien le
festival imago je connais bien tout ce
qui se passe bien sur le territoire et
vidéo à l autre et je trouve comme je
dis que la france ait des généreuses qui
a plein de générosité que est vraiment
il ya un élan et comme vous dites il
faut que les institutions accompagne est
de mutualiser d'air parce que c'est
vraiment vraiment très important parce
que vous dire je fais quelque chose tout
a été dit je pense que tout a été dit je
suis
oui je pense qu'on a encore des choses à
faire mais là en tout cas moi je vois
aussi les jeunes qui arrivent à les
êtres pour certains ils sont aussi un
peu militant donc je pense que si ça va
passer par eux parce qu'il y en a qu à
rêver qu'ils disent oui je suis
handicapé est alors regardez cette
compétence là donc je pense que ça peut
aussi passer par eux
ces jeunes qui arrivent et qui ont eu un
parcours de vie voilà qui est plus ou
moins compliquées mais voilà qui peuvent
être là aussi en tant que militant et
aussi la canton
je voulais juste rajouter on voit bien
aussi les fameux accident de la vie je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
aussi elles doivent être aussi attentif
à ça parce qu'on a quand même dans le
handicap psychique où on parle des
risques psychosociaux et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai risque et on a des gens qui
peuvent être en burn out et qui
n'arrivent pas à rentrer et qui viennent
en esat un peu pour reprendre confiance
en eux et reprendre un rythme de travail
et donc ça ça existe c'est vrai qu'on
peut être valises un jour et d'un coup
être voilà handicapés dans certaines
situations
le lendemain mais donc ça c'est vrai
qu'il faut donc on profite de la vie
tous voila et je pense que c'est ça qui
est chouette c'est sur ces mots je
propose mes dames qu'on constate cette
émission c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés merci à toutes les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour
échanger sur ce sujet mangane le gros on
vous retrouve bientôt sur notre antenne
pour votre émission avec les yeux de
morgan 1 et bouquets les olympiades de
cette année sont malheureusement
reportée pour des raisons sanitaires
mais le rendez-vous est bien sûr donné
pour 2021 et oriane minot vous l'avez
dit votre établissement est partenaire
du festival
imago qui a débuté le 19 septembre
dernier vos artistes seront en
représentation c'est le samedi 10
octobre au théâtre de belleville à paris
pour une lecture spectacle et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]